mais si si au pied là quelqu'un vient
ici diana s'est couché ya quelqu'un
bonjour monsieur oui c'est mon chien
alors ça vous dérange parce que la
couche est assez au pied bon alors
écoutez je tiens je tiens à vous dire
une chose avant de commencer ce pas je
trouve absolument monstrueux mais
monstrueux
la façon dont on est reçu dans ce
théâtre n'est ce pas alors je devrais
plutôt dire la façon dont on est parti
n'est ce pas parce que c'est un standard
alors non on est là
on arrive ici on est dans le noir la
scène n'est même pas fléchi nikolic ex
un an mais je me suis cassé la binette
là-haut dans une gouttière
allez savoir comment je me suis retrouvé
la route cet instant dalle taisez vous
parlerez aprés noir reste la gta vous
dire une chose malgré tout c'est que
j'ai des relations j'ai le bras long un
resto date
on se retrouvera plus tard dans le
métier croyez moi est plutôt que de
penser comment je le dis tout de suite
oui mais on se retrouvera les jv
d'accord annoncés allez hop on dit que
c'est mon aire de jeu ici on y va je
vais temps je regarde auguste au milieu
de sa gloire
patati patata non je passais mon
instrument on se remet comment peut-on
autres c'est moi ce que je continue mon
sens sont ralliés à massacrer du trône
où je le vois ça me dégoûte mais ça me
dégoûte travailler dans ces mots je je
je je ne sais plus je ne sais plus je me
saborde allez hop et cela et c'est quoi
c'est pour une mort douce comme aux
autres ouvriers crac une mort lui de
voir ce que vous voulez d'ailleurs je
m'en fous complètement
mettons de 1000 membres et n'en parlons
plus le satisfait un mois par je tiens à
vous dire une chose je sais que j'ai
raté mon audition ça je ne sais je tiens
à vous dire une autre chose c'est que
c'est de votre faute
je ne vous dis pas au revoir